THE PEOPLE" COMING TO THEATERS
OCTOBER 4TH, 5TH AND 6TH.
HERE NOW, JUDGE JEANINE PIRRO,
LEO 2.0 TERRELL LEO TERREL.
JUDGE, I'M IMPRESSED, I DON'T
WANT TO LOSE YOU TO HOLLYWOOD, I
DON'T KNOW.
>> ACADEMY AWARD, OSCAR, OSCAR.
>> Sean: HAVE WE ALL HAVE THE
SHARED EXPERIENCE, BASKETBALL
GAME, HOCKEY GAME, BOXING MATCH,
I'VE BEEN TO ALL OF THEM,
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL AND ALL OF
A SUDDEN, EVERYONE, YOU'RE
TALKING TO STRANGERS, YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE PITCHING,
YOU'RE HIGH-FIVING AFTER A
GRAND SLAM OR A SLAM-DUNK OR A
LONG TOUCHDOWN PASS OR A
TOUCHDOWN RUN AND YOUR TEAM GOES
AHEAD.
I'VE DONE IT.
WHY WOULD THEY ADD POLITICS TO
THIS?
JUDGE?
>> FIRST OF ALL, IT'S A MISTAKE
AND BY THE WAY I'M NOT BEING
BLACKLISTED, I DON'T KNOW WHERE
YOU GOT THAT FROM, BUT I THINK
THE PROBLEM RIGHT NOW IS THAT EG
TO MAKE AMERICA SOMETHING THAT
SHE ISN'T.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, SPORTS IS THE
ONE THING THAT GIVES US THE
ABILITY TO HAVE SOME FREE TIME,
MAKE FRIENDS, BE PART OF
SOMETHING TOGETHER.
AND IT'S REVISIONIST HISTORY
WITH THE UNITED STATES ASKING
THE U.N. TO COME INTO AMERICA
AND ASSESS WHETHER OR NOT WE ARE
A RACIST COUNTRY, I'M TELLING
YOU, WHERE THAT'S GOING AS THEY
ARE GOING TO FINALLY SAY WE NEED
TO PAY REPARATIONS, AND THAT IS
WHERE THIS IS ALL GOING.
THEY ARE DESTROYING EVERYTHING
THAT IS AMERICAN.
AND THE NFL, IF THEY WANT TO DO
SOMETHING, IF THEY WANT TO PLAY
TWO ANTHEMS OR WHATEVER, BUT IF
YOU WANT TO CHANGE THINGS IN
AMERICA YOU DON'T DO IT WITH THE
SONG, YOU DO IT BY EFFECTUATING
CHANGE IN COURTS, IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND PEOPLE IN POWER,
IN SCHOOLS AND THE SCHOOL BOARD.
WHICH IS, BY THE WAY, WHAT
"GOD'S NOT DEAD" IS ALL ABOUT.
PARENTS WHOSE CHILDREN ARE BEING
TAUGHT THINGS LIKE CRITICAL RACE
THEORY THAT HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH THEIR BELIEF IN GOD AND
FREEDOM OF SPEECH FOR THAT IS
WHY WE NEED TO KEEP FIGHTING AND
THAT IS WITH THE MOVIE IS ALL
ABOUT.
>> Sean: NOW THAT THEY HAVE
ADDED POLITICS, I DON'T THINK
IT'S BY ACCIDENT, MLB, NBA, NFL,
RATINGS IN SOME CASES DOWN
DRAMATICALLY.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING THEY WANT NO
PART OF THIS.
THAT IS NOT -- WE LOVE THE
SPORT, WE LOVE THIS, WE DON'T
WANT TO BE LECTURED TO DURING
SPORTS.
I THINK THEY ARE DOING GREAT
DAMAGE TO THEIR LEAGUES.
>> I THINK THEY ARE DOING GREAT
DAMAGE BUT IT'S CALLED
APPEASEMENT.
THEY ARE APPEASING THE EXTREME
GROUP, BLACK LIVES MATTER, WHO
SPEAKS FOR NO ONE, WHO
REPRESENTS NO ONE.
I TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
RESPECTFULLY, THEY CAN'T WIN AT
COURT OF LAW.
THEIR POLICIES DO NOT CALL FOR
WORKING WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
THEY WANT TO DESTROY THE SYSTEM.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE TRYING TO
DESTROY OUR SCHOOLS.
THEY ARE INDUSTRIES, THERE IS
CRIME AND THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
ADOPTED THEM AS PART OF THEIR
GROUP.
THEIR FRINGE GROUP AND WHEN THEY
TALK ABOUT RACIAL EQUITY, THAT
GETS TORN APART IN COURT.
ALL THESE PRO, PREFERENTIAL
TREATMENT BASED ON RACE PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN KNOCKED OUT IN COURT.
WHAT WE HAVE IS SPORTS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE AFRAID OF
THESE GROUPS, SO THEY GET SHAKEN
DOWN AND THAT IS WHY YOU HAVE
THE BLACK NATIONAL ANTHEM.
IN CONCLUSION, THERE'S ONLY ONE
NATIONAL ANTHEM.
THERE'S ONLY ONE AMERICAN FLAG.
NOTHING ELSE, NOTHING MORE,
POLITICS SHOULD NOT BE IN
SPORTS.
>> Sean: JUDGE, BY THE WAY,
ANTONIO'S ABOUT SAID
HE WAS BLACKLISTED BY
TRADITIONAL HOLLYWOOD, JUST TO
BE CLEAR FOR YOU, NOT YOUR MOVIE
IN PARTICULAR.
I WANT TO SEE YOU ON THE BIG
SCREEN, I CAN'T WAIT.